this year is the 50th anniversary of
title ix the landmark civil rights law
intended to give women the same access
to sports as men our next guest knows a
thing or two about breaking barriers she
is two-time olympic gold medalist and
women's world cup winner brianna scurry
she was the u.s women's national team's
goalkeeper for 14 years and her
heart-stopping saves earned her a spot
in the national soccer hall of fame
scurry also made her mark as the only
black openly gay player on the field
until a concussion changed her life
forever she tells her story in new
memoir my greatest save and she's the
subject of a new documentary called the
only on paramount plus which like cvs is
a division of the paramount global
family let's take a look
one of the greatest we've ever seen not
just in the us but in the world my kick
is insignificant if she doesn't make a
save she was the right goalkeeper at the
right time
when i look back i feel like i've always
been the only
the only girl the only black kid the
only openly gay player
even on the field i was the only one
that could save us
but the real challenge
was saving myself
that's intense brianna
is also an analyst for paramount plus
soccer coverage and she joins us right
now good morning how are you doing good
morning i'm fantastic how are you good
having me of course so this new
documentary and you wrote a memoir about
your life why is it important now at
this point um to open up and allow
people to see you more than they've ever
seen you before
yes and you sugarcoated nothing
well there's a reason for that i decided
um in 2019 to write a book after sitting
down with my brain trust and i realized
that i had to be completely honest not
only about the great things in my life
but also the stuff that's not so great
and i wanted to really give voice to all
of it and so i realized i was in a place
where i was far enough away from the
really hurtful things that i could speak
about them clearly and and truthfully
and authentically and so i wanted to
make sure that my memoir wasn't wasn't
candy-coated and that it was really true
and authentic now you have overcome a
lot and as athletes
it takes time but we come to a point
where we can talk about what ended our
careers yes i think one thing we don't
talk about because of maybe our ego how
we were taught not to deal with being
vulnerable we don't talk about mental
health and depression
you open up about that
how did you overcome that
well it was such a journey it was
literally a three-year odyssey
i was just detached disconnected i just
had all these symptoms as you know but
also the the emotional side like you
said is something that we really don't
talk about much so i really wanted to
give voice to that as well so one i
finally got the right care that i needed
and i got the a procedure called
occipital nerve release where i had
nerves dug out of the back of my neck
that was the source of great headaches
and then i was able to go from there to
getting a whole year of therapy for all
the other things that were wrong and
finally was able to get out of it
when i was throwing a lifeline in my
deepest depression and i was finally
able to get to the point where
i could get help and and make a make a
rise from there you write so movingly in
the book and it's shown in the
documentary too and i'm so glad to see
your gold medals here because that's a
whole other story you're standing on a
bridge you were thinking about i'm going
to jump in i'm going to take my life you
had a traumatic brain injury you had
broken up with a partner you had no
money right you pawned your gold medals
and you said i might as well end it all
but you didn't right why not rihanna
so at the time my mother was coping with
alzheimer's and she and my father were
the most um advent supporters for me all
my life
and the thought of somebody knocking on
her door notifying her that her baby was
gone
um was something i just couldn't bear
and that's what kept me from doing it
yeah and you said you've walked away and
you've never thought about it since
right so glad to hear that thank you and
your gold medals and in the deepest in
your deepest despair you pawned your
gold medals you take a job at a gank a
bank as a bank teller i can't imagine
what would you like 20s 30 i can't
imagine you're doing that that didn't
last very long right but you pawned your
gold medals because you needed money
that badly i did i was in such despair
everything was crumbling around me i
just remember sliding deeper and deeper
into that depression and at the time i
was declared totally disabled
temporarily at the time and so i was
getting in insurance checks from the
insurance company but they would you
know sometimes pay him sometimes not pay
him and string me along and so i had to
get stability yeah and the only thing i
had a value were my medals do you think
you've gotten credit for your career you
know you have that famous game brandi
chastain took off her shirt and one you
know when you won but you saved the kick
i did you saved the kick that allowed
the u.s to win yes i did and all the
focus was on her not dissing brandy at
all of course of course but there was do
you feel hey what about me did you ever
feel that or did you feel
snubbed or neglected people felt that
for you but did you even as you came out
of the game yeah to reflect on your
career right right i appreciate it i i
did i did feel underappreciated that's a
great word um after long time after
because i remember thinking and when
people were saying that to me oh i
didn't see you enough you didn't get the
accolades i remember thinking oh really
i didn't realize that you felt that way
and then i started to think about it and
magnifies it and it magnified it and i
realized it might be more than just my
position as a goalkeeper it might be
that i'm openly gay it also might be
that i'm african-american so i as time
went on i realized that that might be a
factor yeah you've called your wife the
uh greatest angel of all and i see that
beautiful ring there how did she change
your life
well you know what after i realized i
wasn't going to commit suicide with my
with my mom's memory um in my head
chrissa came into my life um haphazardly
uh a chance uh
uh
dinner with naomi gonzalez and her and
they only told chris about my plight
with the insurance company and that i
needed this procedure and they weren't
doing the right thing and she's the one
as she was a pr um owner she got it done
she got it you and chris has saved each
other honestly it's a beautiful
relationship well brian thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate you
thank you for having me we're also
thankful that you didn't jump that yes
we are we're meant to be here the only
doc the documentary comes out july 12th
on paramount plus her memoir my greatest
save is available now we will be right
back